this beginner's course will help you
learn the fundamentals of programming
with
visualbasic.net visual basic is an
object-oriented programming language
developed by microsoft it's often used
to make desktop apps for windows but you
can use the programming language for a
wide variety of applications and not
just on windows
kevin drum teaches this course
kevin is the head of computer science at
a school in the uk kevin will teach you
everything from getting visual studio
set up for programming to understanding
the basic constructs of high-level
programming languages
this is an excellent course for anyone
who wants to learn visual basic leave a
comment with the most interesting thing
you learned in this course
in this series of videos i'm going to
introduce you to programming with visual
basic.net inside visual studio
so let's begin by launching visual
studio and taking a look at some of the
features
exactly what you see here will depend on
which version of visual studio you're
using you can see that i'm using visual
studio 2019
but essentially the features will be the
same you can see i have a list of my
most recently used projects on the left
hand side
on the right i'm going to choose the
option to create a new project
and again what you see next will depend
on which version of visual studio you're
using it will also depend on which
programming languages you installed
you can see that i've installed a number
of different programming languages which
tells you visual studio itself is not a
programming language it's an environment
in which you can use a programming
language i'm going to use visual basic
on the right hand side i can see a
number of different project templates
which i can choose from
and i'm going to create a windows forms
app so with the correct option chosen
click next
you're now invited to give the project a
name
it's offering me the name windows app2
this is because it's the second
application which i've created
it's not a very meaningful name so i
strongly recommend that you change that
perhaps
perhaps not i think that's been done
before
that'll do for now you also need to be
mindful of where the project will be
saved the location of your project you
can see the location of mine will be d
visual studio 2019 projects but you can
change this in fact i'll show you later
that once you're in visual studio you
can change the default location
this is particularly important if you're
working in a school or a college or an
organization
it may be that you only have permission
to save visual studio projects in
particular locations
notice there's a browse button here if
you do want to change the location
my solution has the same name as the
project i'll say a little bit about the
difference between a solution and a
project in a moment
and i'm going to say that i want to
place the solution and the project in
the same directory by ticking this box
since this is a brand new project i'm
not going to worry too much about which
version of the net framework i'm using
more about that later as well so let's
hit create
and here is visual studio
i can see a little message on the bottom
right there telling me that there's a
new version of visual studio which can
be downloaded i'll maybe do that a
little bit later i'll just ignore it for
now
now there are lots of options here which
i'll be talking about as we go along but
suffice to say for now we have a menu of
options across the top and each of these
has a number of sub options which in
turn might have a number of sub options
there's a toolbar
i can add extra toolbars which you'll
see later
but the most useful one is here to start
with
on the right hand side i can see my
solution explorer
a solution is a collection of files that
make up my application
and we'll take a closer look at these
files later
i have a properties window which will
become important when i start building
my user interface
and on the left hand side there's a
toolbox if i just click on this
it will move into view
if i click away from it it disappears i
actually like the toolbox in place all
the time so i'm going to click on this
little drawing pin
to keep it there
and i can resize it if i need to
in the middle i've got my form this is
where i'm going to start building my
user interface
so let's write some code
i'm going to start by dropping a button
onto the form
so from my toolbox i click on button
draw the button onto the form
because the button is selected i can see
properties of the button in the
properties window on the right hand side
i can see for example we have the text
property of the button which is
currently button one i'm going to change
that
to press here and notice how it's
changed the appearance of the button on
the form
the other thing i want to change is the
name of the button
every object that you place on a form
will have a name property now it's
currently button one because it's the
first button which i placed on the form
and i could leave it as button one but i
want to start using a naming convention
btn in lowercase because it's a button
and then something meaningful which
tells me what the button does for
example start you could call the button
pretty much anything you like as long as
the name doesn't start with a number and
as long as there are no spaces or
special characters like question marks
or exclamation marks in there
this naming convention makes it clear
what the button does and it also makes
it clear that it's a button and that
will become important later on when i
start writing code
there are other properties which i can
change as well for example the
background color
and i have a color palette here which i
can use
we'll stick with this for now but you'll
learn about other properties as and when
you need them
what i want to do now is write some code
that will run when the user of my
application clicks on the button
to write some code for the button
i can double click it
the way to think of this is that the
code is behind the form
my form is still there you can see
there's a tab here
that's the design view of my form and
this is the visual basic view of my form
notice that the toolbox no longer has
anything on it because it's
inappropriate to use it while i'm coding
i have line numbers down the left hand
side
to be honest i don't like these and i'll
turn them off in a moment
and i can see some code already there
and i have to be very careful not to
break it
for example i can see public class form
1 at the top
and end class at the bottom
i'm not going to change this these need
to be in place in order for the form to
work
later when you find out more about
object oriented programming these two
lines will make more sense
i can also see the stub of a procedure
which will run when the button is
clicked
private sub button start click notice
that's the name that i gave to my button
and notice that it's going to handle the
click of the button
to be more precise it will handle the
click event of the button object
there's also some stuff going on in
brackets here
these are called parameters and you'll
find out more about parameters later
suffice to say leave this exactly as it
is for now
we're going to write code between sub
and end sub
so i'm just going to press the enter key
a few times and give myself some more
room
i can also give myself some more room
above the procedure
and below the procedure
sub by the way stands for sub procedure
so let's write our first program
i'm going to use the message box command
notice i'm typing in lowercase
and as i type
a list of options has appeared
visual studio is looking at the letters
i'm typing and offering me a command to
choose from so i can see msg box here
i can ignore it and carry on typing or i
can actually select it from the list
i'll show you how we can do this more
quickly in a moment
i'll just press the space bar
and i'm going to open a bracket
and again there's some more information
appearing on the screen it's quite
daunting the first time you see this but
as you get used to it you'll find it's
incredibly useful
again i'm just going to ignore it
notice how visual studios automatically
put the closing bracket on there for me
i'm going to open a double quote
and again visual studio has
automatically put the closing double
quote on there
and finally i'll type the text of my
message
hello world
all kinds of things have happened here
for example
notice that msg box has automatically
recapitalized that tells me that i typed
it correctly i'm getting visual feedback
notice also the color coding the literal
string which i'm using in my text
message is colored differently from the
command itself
again i'm getting visual feedback on how
to use this this is why it's called
visual studio
let's put another message in
now i've just typed the first few
letters this time and i'm going to press
the tab key on my keyboard
to select the rest of it
i've saved myself some typing
when you get used to it you can write
code very very quickly
hello world how are you
and one more
spelling mistake there i'm just going to
hold down my control key and tap the
left arrow key which will jump me one
word at a time through that text
and then i can correct my spelling
to be honest it doesn't matter what i
put inside these double quotes it won't
be a problem if on the other hand i
mistyped the command
i see a red wiggly line underneath it
telling me that i've made an error this
is what we call a syntax error i'm
breaking the rules of the programming
language if i move my mouse over it i
can see some kind of error message there
msg boxes not declared
visual studio thinks i'm trying to use
something called a variable and i
haven't announced that i want to use it
more about variables later on
let's just get rid of this line
altogether
okay so there's my program i'll just
close up a little bit of the white space
i don't need it and i'm going to run the
code
there's a start button at the top
and my form is now on the screen
and to test it i'll simply click on the
button
there's my first message
there's my second message
and there's my third message
and the program has stopped running
my procedure may have stopped running
but the application itself is still
running the form is still on the screen
and i can stop this running by pressing
the red square up here or i can simply
close the form with the red cross here
and everything is stopped
so there we have it our first program
which is just a sequence of messages
but it's a program
there's one more thing i want to do now
and that is to save my work
remember a visual studio application can
consist of several files so rather than
just clicking this little button here
which will save the form i'm going to
click this button which will save all of
the files in my application
i can now close down visual studio and
return to my application tomorrow
in this video i just want to show you
how we can customize the integrated
development environment the ide that is
visual studio so let's start it up again
and i'm going to open up the project
that i was working on last time
notice that it's in the recent files
list so i could just click on it here
alternatively i can click on open a
project or solution let's do it this way
for now so we can see which file we need
to open up
here's my d drive
this is where i'm storing my projects
and here's the one i was working on last
time notice it's a folder
inside that folder
there's a solution file sln
that's the file which ties together all
of the other files that make up my
application that's the file which i need
to open
and here's the application i was working
on last time
here's my form
and here's the code behind it
a little word of warning first of all
sometimes you might accidentally double
click on the background of the form
itself watch what happens when i do this
i've got another procedure stub here
called form1 load
any code which i write in here will
automatically run when i run up the
application which will cause the form to
load
but i don't need this so i'm going to
get rid of it i'm simply going to delete
this procedure stub
another word of warning you might
accidentally or even deliberately click
on this where it says one reference
let's take a look
i've clicked on that something has
appeared and i'm going to click on this
as well
i have another tab across the top and
what i can see here looks very
complicated indeed
this is code which runs when you run the
form but you don't really need to see it
if you're a beginner
in fact it's quite daunting when you
look at it
suffice to say for now it's actually
initializing the form it's setting up
the form and it's placing the button on
there and it's changing various
properties of the button
i strongly recommend you leave this
alone until you have a better
understanding of what it does i'm just
going to close down this tab
and i'm back to something more familiar
anyway what i want to talk about now is
how we can customize this programming
environment
you were given some options when you ran
it up for the first time
but you can change those options inside
tools
options
notice i'm using a color theme blue
but you can change it to dark if you
wish some people much prefer this
to be honest i don't i prefer black on
white not white on black
it really is a matter of preference i'm
going to switch it back to the way it
was
i can also have finer control over the
keyword colors and over the text colors
and any other colours that you see on
here for that matter
we can do this by selecting fonts and
colours
you can see there's a lot of options
here
keyword the default color is blue
and i can switch that to magenta
you do need to be a little bit careful
though because some colors have special
meanings
and it can start looking very messy as
well
if needs be you can change things back
notice there's an option here to use
defaults
some people like to increase the font
size as well
it's entirely up to you
something else i want to change to give
myself some more room on the screen is
to switch off these line numbers
i can do that by going to
text editor
all languages
and then here line numbers
notice i can have different
configurations depending on the
programming language i'm using
and there's one more thing i want to
change and that's some of the default
file locations
i can do that underneath projects and
solutions
locations
you can see i've already set my
project's location to my d drive
needless to say there are lots more
options which you can set in here and
i'll be honest i don't know what half of
them are
but when i need them i'll find them
click ok for your changes to take effect
in this video about visual basic.net i
want to say more about output
and i'm going to introduce you to
variables
i'll start by creating a new project
as before it'll be a windows forms
application in visual basic
give the project a meaningful name
and think about where it's going to be
saved
you can change this if necessary
let's start with a button on the form
and i'm going to rename the button get
in the habit of renaming things that you
place on the form as you go along
btn that's my convention
and then go this is called camel
notation because of the capital g it
looks like a camel with a hump on its
back
i'm also going to change the text
property of the button
and let's write some code that will run
when the user clicks on the button
to get to the code behind the form i
double-click the button
let me just remind you you mustn't
change or delete this
if you do you'll start seeing errors on
the screen watch
straight away i've got a syntax error up
here
class statement must end with matching
end class i'll just use the undo button
to put it back again
and i'm going to give myself some white
space just give myself a bit more room
on the screen here
we've already seen that we can display a
message on the screen using the message
box command like this
to test it i simply press the start
button that will run the form up
and then i can run my code by clicking
on the button itself
now there are three
fundamental constructs when it comes to
programming that i'd like to mention now
the first of these is sequence
the second is selection which you'll see
in a later video and the third is
iteration which you'll also see in a
later video for now let's just say a
little bit about sequence
sequence simply means that each
statement in a program or a block of
code will run one after another in
sequence
so for example i could display each of
these words separately
run the program
press the button
and one message after another
and i'll stop my application with this
red square
if i want to display these words in
reverse order i can simply change the
order of the commands
i'm just dragging and dropping
and tidy up some of the white space
you can have as much or as little white
space as you like whatever makes it easy
for you to read the program
let's give this a try
before i continue and talk about
variables i just want to show you
another command i can use to display a
message on the screen
messagebox
dot show
let's take a look
this is another message it does exactly
the same thing
to be honest this is a bit of an old
style command which has existed from
very early versions of visual basic
this is a more modern way of doing
things
this is an
object-oriented approach
and it'll make more sense why you might
do it this way later when you find out
more about object oriented programming
for now you can either use msgbox or
messagebox.show i'm going to continue
with msg box
so now let's talk about
variables
i'll start by placing another button on
the form because i want to write a
separate procedure
switch to the form
and drop another button on there
notice i'm getting some guidelines as i
drag the button around and resize it
this helps me to create a nice layout
for my form
okay let's get in the good habits of
naming objects as we go along so i'm
going to call this btn variables
and i'll change the text property as
well
to write the code as before double click
and you can see i now have a new
procedure stub
i can start writing my code here
let's give myself a little bit more
white space below and a little bit less
at the top here
so what is a variable
well a variable is actually a location
in the computer's memory where a program
can temporarily store data while it's
running
and while that sounds a little bit
complicated they're actually very easy
to set up and use
let's say for example i want to create a
variable to store somebody's first name
the first thing i need to do is declare
it i need to announce that i want to use
a new variable and i do this using the
dim statement like this
now there are a number of things going
on in this command
first of all the word dim
is short for dimension because i'm
actually setting aside a certain amount
of memory i'm specifying the size or the
dimension of the variable
the amount of memory being set aside
depends on this which is the data type
of the variable
when it comes to string variables one
byte of memory will be needed for each
character in the string
but to be honest i don't need to worry
too much about that
visual basic will look after the memory
for me or to be more precise the runtime
engine that visual basic depends on will
take care of the memory for me
the other thing i'm doing is i'm giving
my variable a name and again notice that
i'm using camel notation and i've
prefixed it with st because it's a
string variable that's just a convention
which i'm going to encourage you to use
you might want to know what data type a
variable is just by glancing at its name
so that's my variable declaration
i've got a green wavy line underneath it
to tell me that i haven't done anything
with it yet unused local variable
so let's now assign a value to it
notice i'm typing in lowercase
i'm being offered the name of the
variable in a list so i'll just press
the tab key to select it
and i'll say st first name is equal to
my first name
notice that the green wavy line has
disappeared now because i'm using the
variable in earlier versions of visual
basic you would have to use the let
command in front of this you'd say let
st first name equal kevin let it become
kevin in this version of visual basic we
don't use let at all
but what you need to appreciate here is
i'm putting the string kevin into that
piece of memory which i set aside
because the string is one two three four
five characters long it's going to take
up five bytes of memory
as i said before though you don't really
need to worry too much about that
okay now i'm going to output the
contents of that variable and i'll do
that using messagebox
notice that i haven't put double quotes
around the name of the variable because
i want to output its contents i don't
literally want to output the string st
first name
let's see what happens
i'm outputting the contents of the
variable
i want to make the message a little bit
more friendly
so i'm going to join the contents of the
variable
with some literal text
like this
you can see that this is a literal
string because it's inside double quotes
and this is the contents of my variable
and i'm using the concatenation operator
which is an ampersand
to join the two together we call this
string concatenation
i can concatenate something onto the end
of it as well
again another concatenation operator
let's see the effect
hello and welcome kevin i hope you are
well
i want you to notice
that i put spaces inside these text
strings
notice there's a space after the letter
e let's just remove it for a second and
see what happens i've also got a space
there inside the string immediately
before the eye i'll just take that out
as well look what happens
you can see the message is a little bit
messy
let's tidy it up
okay i'm going to declare another
variable
to hold my last name
so another dim statement
and i'll assign a value to this variable
as well
and i'll include the last name as part
of the message
a common mistake is to not use enough
ampersands watch what happens if i get
rid of this one
you can see i have a syntax error
the message isn't particularly helpful
but i know that there's something wrong
with the way i've concatenated this
string together so let's put the
concatenation operator back in place
another common mistake is not to use
enough double quotes so again i'll take
out one of those double quotes and you
can see that the whole thing seems to be
a problem
one little error and i've got red wavy
lines all over the place
this is not particularly helpful
just remember
double quotes and brackets come in pairs
if you have an opening double quote
there has to be a matching closing
double quote if you have an opening
bracket there has to be a matching
closing bracket
let's try this
now you can see kevin drum has come out
as one word there's no space in between
the two
i can fix this easily
i need to concatenate a space
in between those two variables
a space is just another character let's
take a look
much better
notice that i've put my dim statements
my variable declarations at the top of
the procedure
i didn't have to do this
as long as i declare a variable before i
try to assign a value to it i can put my
dim statement wherever i like so for
example
i could declare the last name here and
then assign a value to it
that's absolutely fine
what i mustn't do
is try to assign a value to it
before i declare it
you can see i have a syntax error local
variable st last name cannot be used
before it has been declared
the sequence of operations is important
although what you can see here is
perfectly okay i like to put all of my
declarations at the top of the procedure
keep them all together
it actually makes the code easier to
manage particularly when you have a lot
of code
i told you that a variable was a
temporary storage location which your
program can use while it's running
when this program has done its job and
it comes to an end the memory being used
by the variables will be released it'll
be freed up for something else to use
but i can change the contents of a
variable while the program is running
that's why it's called a variable its
contents can vary
so for example i can do this
i'm just going to copy these two lines
of code paste them underneath
they're still part of the procedure
and i'm assigning new values to those
variables which i'll output in the same
way as i did before i can just borrow
this line of code and copy it
so watch what happens when i run the
program
hello and welcome kevin drumm i hope you
are well
hello and welcome mervyn drake i hope
you are well
this makes the point that the contents
of a variable can change
while the program is running
i can assign different values to those
variables
at run time
in the next video i'll say more about
the different data types that you can
use when you declare a variable
and what implications this has for your
code
in this video i want to say more about
different variable data types
i'm going to store some details about a
car let's start with a new button on the
form
give it a name
and change the text property
double-clicking
will allow me to write the code
okay so i'm going to start with a couple
of string variables to store the make
and the model
we've come across string variables
already let's assign some values
a ford escort a classic car
i also want to store the number of doors
that this car has
this time i'm using a data type of
integer
an integer is just another name for a
whole number
notice the naming convention i'm using i
doors i for integer
i want to store the color of the car
this is going to be another string
variable
i want to store some information about
whether or not this car has been taxed
this time i'm using a data type of
boolean named after the computer
scientist george boole
a boolean variable can have one of two
values true or false
this car has been taxed
boolean variables are good when you have
yes no type data for example whether
somebody is a vegetarian or not whether
something is switched on or something is
switched off
i also want to store the engine size
another integer
1200cc
i'd like to store the price of this car
i'm using a data type of decimal
decimal is the most suitable data type
when you want to store money values
i could have used double and i could
have used single because all three data
types decimal double single allow me to
have a decimal point with decimal places
after it
but double is twice as accurate as
single
i can have more decimal places
and the data type decimal is the most
accurate of them all which makes sense
when you're doing calculations with
money
the final thing i want to store is the
date that the car was registered so i'm
going to use a data type of date
there's a special way that i have to
assign a value to a data variable
notice i'm using the hash symbols to
enclose the date
i should also point out that this is not
the 11th of february but the 2nd of
november
when you type a date you need to type it
in american format which is the month
followed by the day followed by the year
when i display this on the screen for
example in a message box it'll be
displayed according to the settings in
my computer's control panel
you'll see in a moment that my computer
is set up to display dates in british
format
now let's build a message box command to
display all of this data
notice the concatenation operators
between the variable names and notice
also that i'm concatenating spaces
between these data items
now you can see i have a bit of a
problem here with reading the code i've
written on the screen
nevertheless let's test it and see if it
runs
there's my message and it looks okay
notice that the day and the month of the
date are the other way around from the
way i coded it i've written the date in
american format but it's being displayed
in british format
what i'd really like to be able to do is
display each data item on a separate
line within the same message box
let's see how to do that
instead of concatenating spaces in
between each data item i'm going to type
a special constant i'll say more about
constants later suffice to say i'm just
going to type
vbnewline
and i'll replace each space with this
let's just copy and paste it ctrl c to
copy
ctrl v to paste
i still need the same number of
concatenation operators to join all
these different bits and pieces together
let's see how it looks now
well that is certainly a nicer message
but now i want to do something about the
problem that i can't actually read the
whole line of code
i could give myself some more space on
the screen by just dragging this bar
across a little bit but even then i
can't read the whole line of code
i essentially want to wrap this text on
the screen
well i can do this
after the ampersand here
in fact i can put this pretty much
anywhere i'm just going to leave a space
and then type an underscore character
when i press enter i've moved the rest
of the line onto the next line down
i can do that again here
notice the underscore characters have
actually disappeared but this is still
just one line of code it won't change
the appearance of the message box
but it just allows me to read the code
more easily on the screen
let's make sure it still works
yeah that's absolutely fine
in the next video i'll show you how we
can capture input from the user of an
application
so we can assign the contents of these
variables at runtime rather than hard
coding the data like we've done here
i want to show you how to capture input
from the user of your application and
i'll be doing it by means of this form
and you'll also see how to use some of
these extra controls that we can place
onto a form
before i do let me just show you a quick
and easy way we can capture input from
the user by means of the input box
function
i'll drop a button on the form first
give it a name
and a text property
double-click to write the code
the input box function will capture one
piece of data specifically it'll capture
a string
i'll need a variable to put that piece
of data into so let's declare a string
variable first of all
and then i can assign a value to it by
means of the input box function just
like this
and to prove it works i'll output the
contents of that variable
i'm concatenating the word hello in
front of it let's give it a try
press the button to launch the procedure
and there's the input box prompt please
enter your first
name that's working fine
so it's a quick and easy way to prompt
the user for some input but what i
really want to talk about in this video
is how we can use controls on the form
to capture input
so i'm going to delete the code you can
see here
and do something else instead
let's go back to the form
i'm going to place a text box on the
form
here it is in the control toolbox
i'll give the text box a name
notice at the moment it's called text
box one
i've prefixed the new name with txt to
indicate that it's a text box and then
i'm calling it first name because that's
the data i want to capture i'm trying to
keep the name meaningful
notice the camel notation as well you'll
see the benefit of doing it this way in
a few moments
i'm also going to put a label on the
form so that the user of the form knows
what to type into the text box
here's the label control
and again i'm going to change its name
to keep it meaningful
lbl for a label
and then something to indicate its
purpose
a label also has a text property which
i'm going to change
and you can see that is what appears on
the form
while i'm at it i'm going to add another
text box to capture the user's last name
and a matching label
and one more text box to capture the
user's gender
notice that a text box also has a text
property but anything i type in here
will actually appear in the text box it
will become the default data if a user
doesn't type something into the text box
i'm going to leave it blank
and we'll have another matching label to
go with this text box
there are a couple of things you need to
be aware of when you're placing controls
on the form
each control must have a unique name
so this one you can see i called it txt
first name
there's the name property and this one i
called txt last name
let me just make the mistake of giving
this text box the same name as the other
one and see what happens
property value is not valid
take a look at the details
and it's telling me that the name is
already in use by another component
something else on the form has already
been called txt first name
if this happens just cancel and find out
which one is the offending control
something else i should mention is you
can't have spaces in a control name so
let's put a space in this text box name
again an error message
and maybe i'll even try putting a
question mark on the end of the name
another error message
so there are some limitations as to what
you can call a text box or indeed any
other control on the form
the text property on the other hand of a
label or a button can be pretty much
anything you like
okay let's just tidy up the layout a
little bit
i'm watching the guidelines for
assistance
and you can also use the format menu to
help you control the layout of a form
see i have options for alignment
horizontal and vertical spacing this one
is particularly handy if i select all of
these text boxes
i can say i want to make them all the
same width for example and i can make
them all the same height
if i want to move things around as a
group i just draw a box around them to
highlight them and i can drag them to a
new position
you can play around with the various
tools available to improve the cosmetic
appearance of your form when you have
time but for now i just want to show you
how we can capture some data so let's
write the code for the button
i'm going to start by declaring three
variables into which i'm going to load
the data that i capture
i'm using a standard naming convention
again st because these are string
variables and then of course something
meaningful in camel notation
i've just spotted a spelling mistake as
well let's fix this
now i'm going to take the information
that the user types onto the form
and load it into these variables
starting with the first name
st first name equals
a single equal sign means i'm about to
assign something to this variable
and the information i want
is on the form in a text box called
txt first name
i've just typed the first three
characters of the text box name txt and
i'm being presented with a list of the
text boxes on the form you can see why i
use this naming convention as long as i
make sure that all of my text boxes
begin with txt i'll get a nice little
list of them
so i'll select txt first name and i want
to take the text property
in other words the text that the user
typed into that text box and i'm going
to load that into my variable
so this reads as take the text
from the text box called txt first name
and assign it to that variable
let's do the same with the other
variables
and finally i'm going to output the data
in a message box just to make sure it
worked
i've included a space between the first
name and the last name
and i've concatenated some extra text in
my message as well let's see what
happens when we run it then
type in some information
and there's the output from my procedure
if i dismiss the message box the
application is still running
so i can change the data here
the program is assigning new values to
those variables overwriting the existing
ones
one more time
so there you have it capturing data from
a user by means of text boxes on a form
let's quickly take a look at another
control which i can use on the form
i want to show you a list box
and i'm going to use this to capture the
user's occupation
so let's give it a name
lst occupation lst because it's a list
box
i'll put a label on the form to go with
it so that the user knows what the list
box is for
and i'm going to include some
occupations in the list box that the
user can choose from
first of all make sure that the list box
is actually selected
and then use the items property
there's a little button here which will
allow me to add a collection of items
click ok and i now have a populated list
box
let's capture the user's selection
i need a variable to store it in
and i can capture the user's selection
in a slightly different
way i'm using the selected item property
let's try it out
hello kevin drumm you are a male teacher
i can also add items to the list box
programmatically in other words in my
code
i'll quickly show you this and then you
can experiment with it yourself
you might remember in an earlier video i
showed you how you could write code when
the form loads
i'm going into the form design
environment and i'll double click the
form itself
i now have a procedure called form1 load
any code i write here will run
immediately after i start the
application but before the form appears
on the screen and i'm going to add some
extra code to put a few more items into
my list box
i am adding something to the collection
of items
which are inside that list box
i'm just going to make sure that the
list box is big enough to display
everything
and let's give it a try
hello beatrix potter you are a female
writer
before we look at some more code
i want to introduce you to some of the
facilities that come with visual studio
for debugging your code in other words
tracking down errors in the code
the first and probably most useful one
that i want to talk about is being able
to set a breakpoint and then step
through the code
i can set a breakpoint by clicking on
the grey bar here
that's a break point
now i'm going to run the program watch
what happens
i'm now in what's called
break mode
or debugging mode
my application ran at full speed until
it came to the break point and now it's
suspended and i can step through the
code one line at a time there are a
number of buttons i can use to do this
up here
step into
step over
step out i'll say more about these two
later the most useful one is step into
notice i can also use the function key
f8 to do the same thing so when i click
the button
i'm getting a message about how the
stepping facility will behave i'm not
too worried about this for now i'm just
going to say i don't want to see these
messages again
it's highlighting the line of code that
it's about to execute next
and now it's about to execute this line
of code
and again
it's about to execute this line of code
when i'm in debug mode i can hover over
the name of a variable to see its
contents
so i can see that the string male has
been assigned to this variable
drum has gone into this one
and kevin has gone into that one
if i take a look at this variable it
hasn't been assigned a value yet because
this line hasn't executed yet
let's continue stepping
and i can see there's something inside
that variable now
final line of code in this procedure
will do some output
so i've been switched back to the user
interface
and finally the procedure will come to
an end
my application is still running the form
is still on the screen but the procedure
which i launched when i clicked on the
button has now finished
i can use as few or as many break points
as i like i'm going to remove this break
point just by clicking on it again and
i'll place a break point here instead
i'm also going to place a break point on
the forms load event handler
let's run it again
now as i told you in the previous video
when you launch a windows forms
application the form is loaded into
memory before it hits the screen so the
forms load event handler is running
first
i'll step through that
and it's populating the list box
when that's complete
the form can hit the screen
and clicking the button causes the
button's click event handler to start
running
and we've seen this before
when we're in debug mode there's some
extra windows that you might want to
switch on a particularly useful one is
called the locals window
you can find it here
on the debug menu
debug windows
locals
what it's showing me is the contents of
any local variables in other words
variables which have been declared
within this procedure
i'll say more about the difference
between local and global variables later
on suffice to say for now this is an
alternative way of finding out what's
inside a variable i can see a nice
summary down here
there's additional information in this
window as well which pertains to these
parameters which i mentioned in another
video we'll say more about these later
with the locals window i can actually
change the contents of a variable on the
fly as it were
i just double click it here
and retype it
i've overwritten the existing value of
that variable
if you've finished stepping through your
program you can stop the execution just
by clicking on this red square or you
can press continue and it will jump you
straight to the next breakpoint if there
is one
at this point i just want to return to a
type of error that you've seen already
and that's the so-called syntax error
for example if i misspell the word text
i type text on the end
i've got a red wavy line
if i open a bracket but forget to close
it
again that's a syntax error
i can see a red wavy line on the end of
this
keep an eye out for these because your
program won't run properly if you don't
fix them
i like to fix them as i go along but
let's see what happens when i try to run
a program which has got syntax errors
like this in it
there were build errors would you like
to continue and run the last successful
build
well that begs the question what does it
mean by build
so let's say no
and i'm going to switch on something
called the output window
watch what happens when i try to run the
program again
build xero succeeded one failed
this tells us something very important
about vb.net programs
when you write a program you're writing
source code code that a human being can
understand
but before you can run a program it has
to be compiled
what that means is it has to be turned
into machine code binary ones and zeros
that the computer can understand
when you press the start button visual
studio will automatically try to compile
the program first
another name for compiling a program or
compilation is to build the program
so you can see here the program has
failed to compile the build failed and
i'm very kindly being asked would i like
to use the last successful build would i
like to run the version of the program
that compiled successfully previously
well in this case the answer is no i
want to fix this version of the program
so i'm going to click on no
and now i have a list of errors
this is really just a summary of the
same information that i saw with the red
wavy lines
i'm being told that it's expecting a
closing bracket a double click on there
and it jumps me to where i need to do
the fix
and i'm being told that text is not a
member of text box
in other words text is not a property of
a text box a double click and it will
jump me straight to that line i can fix
it here now
as i said before though i like to watch
out for the red wavy lines while i'm
coding and fix them as i go along
i'll show you some more debugging
facilities as and when i need them in
later videos
in this video i'm going to talk about
how we can work with numeric input from
the user in other words how we can do
calculations with number data
before i do i'm going to build myself a
simple little interface with a couple of
text boxes and a button
notice how i've been naming the controls
as i go along this will make the code
easier to understand
the first thing i'd like to do is add
together two numbers that the user types
onto the form
so i'll start by declaring a couple of
variables
remember the data type integer means a
whole number
i'm going to declare another variable to
store the result of the calculation
and now i'm going to capture the data
that the user types into those text
boxes
adding these together couldn't be
simpler
i result equals i number one plus i
number two let's output the result
and see if it works
12 plus 5 is 17.
let's try something
else let's subtract one number from the
other
i result equals i number one minus i
number two i'll just borrow that message
box statement
and we'll run the program again
so that's the two numbers added together
and that's what we get when we subtract
5 from 12.
what about multiplication
to multiply two numbers together we use
an asterisk that's the multiplication
symbol when you're programming
twelve plus five is seventeen
twelve minus five is seven
and twelve times five is sixty
bit of copying and pasting to speed
things up
to divide one number by another use a
forward slash
so this reads as i number one divided by
i number two
twelve plus five is seventeen twelve
minus five is seven
twelve times five is sixty
and twelve divided by five
is two
well not quite but remember we're
working with integers here we're working
with whole numbers
when i divide one integer by another and
store the result in an integer variable
vb is automatically going to round to
the result either up or down
let's improve on this
instead of using integer variables
i'm going to use a real number type
let's use a double
i'm also going to change the naming i've
used here
dbl for a double
strictly speaking it doesn't matter what
i call these variables but i want the
names to be meaningful and i want the
names to reflect the data type
let's see what we get this time
same as before 12 plus 5 is 17 12 minus
5 is 7.
12 times 5 is 60
but 12 divided by 5 is 2.4
that makes more sense
just to be clear about the way a
variable works
i'm multiplying two numbers together
here
and i'm storing the result in this
variable called dbl result
when i perform a second calculation i'm
storing the result in the same variable
what's happening is i'm overwriting the
existing value in dbl result
i lose the value which was generated by
the first calculation
when i do the third calculation i
overwrite the value inside dbl result
again so i lose the result of the second
calculation by the time my program comes
to an end this contains the result of
the first number divided by the second
number
if i wanted to keep the result of each
of these calculations then i should have
declared four separate variables
these are called arithmetic operators
these are the basic operations that we
might want to perform with numbers
there are a couple more let me show you
them
that's the carry symbol which is
normally above the number six on your
keyboard and what it means is raised to
the power of
so it's going to raise number one to the
power of number two
twelve plus five
twelve minus five
twelve times five
twelve divided by five
and twelve to the power of five
that's twelve times twelve times twelve
times twelve times twelve
another useful operator is integer
division
i'm going to use a backslash instead of
a forward slash
in some programming languages you would
use the word div in fact the pseudo code
that you see on most exam papers will
use the word div in visual basic we use
a backslash
let's take a look
that's the effect of using a backslash
instead of a forward slash
12 is being divided by five but only the
whole number part of the result is being
kept
twelve divided by five is two with two
remainder we're ignoring the remainder
let's try fifteen and four
fifteen plus four is nineteen fifteen
minus four is eleven fifteen times four
is sixty fifteen divided by four is
three point seven five
that's fifteen raised to the power of
four
and that's 15 divided by 4 ignoring the
remainder 4 goes into 15 three times
the last arithmetic operator that i'd
like to show you now is mod
number one mod number two
mod is the remainder after whole number
division
let's see what this does
let's go with 24
and 9 this time
i'll just move the form across so you
can see the code as well
24 plus 9 is three
twenty four minus nine is fifteen
twenty four multiplied by nine is two
hundred and sixteen
twenty four divided by 9 is 2.6
recurring the number of decimal places
you can see there is governed by the
data type
24 raised to the power of 9 is this
rather large number
24 divided by 9 using integer division
is 2
9 goes into 24 twice
and 9 goes into 24 twice
with 6 remaining that's what mod is
giving me it's the remainder after whole
number division
let me finish with a word of warning
i'm going to run this program again but
i'm not going to enter any data
i'm going to leave these two text boxes
empty
straight away i have an error message
conversion from string to type double is
not valid
this tells me something about what's
going on behind the scenes
let's stop the program
and put a break point on this line
when you type something into a text box
it's actually a string
notice here text equals 5 7 in double
quotes
when this line of code executes vb will
automatically convert the string five
seven into a number
you can see dbl number one has got a
zero in it at the moment that's the
initial value of any numeric variable
until you assign something else to it
step through the code
the text box contained five seven
but the variable contains fifty seven
behind the scenes visual basic is
automatically converting the string into
a double because it can
but notice that my second text box
contains a zero length string a pair of
double quotes with nothing in between
them it's a string but it just doesn't
have any length
and when this line of code executes vb
will attempt to convert that zero length
string into a number but of course it
can't
and my program has crashed
this is what we call a run time error
the program crashed while it was running
it crashed at run time
another name for a runtime error is an
exception so you can see here i have an
unhandled exception
i'll talk more about runtime error
handling or exception handling in a
later video
but for now with this program we just
have to expect the user to do the right
thing not to leave any of the text boxes
blank
in this video i'll say something about
complex arithmetic
that is arithmetic expressions that
contain more than one arithmetic
operator
let's write some code
let's imagine we're building an
application for a cake shop and the
application will calculate the total
cost of a number of cakes
i'm not going to capture any input i'm
just going to hard code the data to keep
things simple
so i've declared three variables one for
the price of a cake one for the quantity
of cakes and one to store the total cost
of however many cakes being bought
let's initialize these variables with
some data
as i said i'm hard coding the data so i
can focus on the calculations but of
course i would probably want to capture
this data from text boxes on the form
so to calculate the total cost of ten
cakes at a price of five pounds per cake
these are good cakes by the way i'll use
the multiplication operator
and let's output the result
fifty pounds worth of cakes no surprises
there
now suppose for a moment we want to
calculate a discount of let's say two
pounds per cake
you might be tempted to try this
take the original price subtract the
discount
and multiply it by the quantity five
pounds per cake
minus two pounds per cake
that's three pounds per cake multiplied
by ten i might expect a result of thirty
pounds let's take a look
minus 15 pounds
not only are we giving the cakes away
we're giving money to the customers as
well
that's totally unsatisfactory what's
going
on well there's an order of operations
that applies when it comes to complex
arithmetic expressions by a complex
arithmetic expression i simply mean an
expression with more than one operator
this expression includes a minus sign
and the multiply sign
the order of priority is that
multiplication is done first so in this
case the discount is being multiplied by
the quantity which is twenty
and then that is being subtracted from
the price
five minus twenty is indeed minus
fifteen
if i want the discount to be applied
first in other words i want the
subtraction to happen first i can
control it using brackets or parentheses
as they're otherwise known
like this
so now anything inside the brackets will
happen first
and there's the 30 pounds i was
expecting
you may well have come across this
already
you might have heard of bodmas
bodmas stands for brackets order
division multiplication addition and
subtraction
that's the order of priority of the
arithmetic operators
order by the way means exponentiation
raising something to the power of
something else
so what we're saying is anything inside
brackets will be done first if there's
an exponentiation operator in the
expression that will happen next
followed by division multiplication
addition
and subtraction
the truth is division and multiplication
have the same priority
also addition and subtraction have the
same priority
so perhaps we should say
to indicate the fact
by the way
i typed a single apostrophe before i
wrote this
this is not code this is simply a
comment which i've added to my code
comments aren't executed they're not
part of the program
a comment is just something that i can
put in my code to help me to understand
it
now let's suppose for a moment i want to
add a charge for postage and packaging
to the total cost of this order
we'll have a flat charge of three pounds
and i'm just going to add it to the end
of this calculation
thinking about the order of operations
whatever's in brackets will happen first
then that will be multiplied by the
quantity
and then finally the postage will be
added on so i don't actually need to
include any brackets here
33 pounds as expected
but there's nothing to stop you from
adding brackets if it helps you to
understand the code so for example i
might do this
i'm saying do all of this first and then
have the postage at the end
something else you may have come across
is this
pemdas
this stands for
it's essentially the same thing as
bodmas
you might have noticed that the m and
the d are the other way around
but that just makes the point that the
order of operations when it comes to
division and multiplication is
irrelevant
now beware you might come across this
that's the cost of my cakes
that's 10 minus five plus two
of course ten minus five is five plus
two is seven
that is ten plus two
minus five
ten plus two is twelve minus five is
also seven all i've actually done is
swap around the order of the operations
but ten minus two plus five
is thirteen
let's be clear i haven't just swapped
around the order of the operations i'm
changing the number which i'm
subtracting from 10 10 minus 2 is 8 plus
5 is 13. it's a different calculation
the same applies here
in the first two examples all i've done
is change the order of operations i've
got 10 divided by 5 times 2 or 2 times
ten divided by five
but in the third example it's a
different calculation
it's five divided by two
multiplied by ten
so beware
bodmas and pemdas both apply they do
tell us the order of operations when it
comes to complex calculations
but complex calculations can also be
quite deceptive
there are three fundamental constructs
in most high-level procedural
programming languages such as vb.net
and they are sequence
selection
and iteration
in this video i'm going to introduce
selection
that means executing one block of code
or another depending on the outcome of a
test
one way we can do this is using the if
statement
let's start with a simple user interface
i've said it before and i'll say it
again get in the habit of naming your
form controls as you place them on the
form
i'm going to ask the user what country
they come from and then give them an
appropriate greeting
i'll capture the input from the form by
assigning it to a variable
and now i'm going to use an if statement
to test the contents of that variable
if the country is equal to australia
then i'm going to output the message
g'day mate
i want you to notice that i'm using the
equal sign to check if two things are
equal
whereas here i'm using the equal sign to
assign something to a variable
in some programming languages you'll use
a slightly different approach
for example in python if you were
checking for equality you would use two
equal signs
in vb a single equal sign can be used
either for checking or for assignment
so let's try it out
if i input australia
i get the australian greeting
if i input something else
nothing at all
that doesn't mean my code isn't working
it's doing exactly what it's supposed to
do
this is what we call a one line if
statement
i can execute one command depending on
the outcome of the test
but if i want to execute multiple
commands depending on the outcome of a
test i'm going to use a block if
statement
i've moved that command to the next line
down
visual studio has automatically added an
end if
and now between the if and the end if i
can have as many commands as i like
so watch what happens now
g'day mate
good on ya
no worries
if i don't type australia if i type
something else
nothing happens at all
now a word of warning if i put something
after the word then
that's a syntax error
end if must be preceded by a matching if
this line of code is complete it's
syntactically correct
however you can't have an end if on its
own
if you're going to use a block if there
should be nothing after the word then
if there's nothing after the word then
and i forget to use end if
again i've got a syntax error
if must end with a matching end if
so you have a choice you can either use
a block if or a one line if but
whichever one you use you have to use it
correctly
when it comes to a block if i can have
multiple else if clauses as part of it
like this
else if country equals france bonjour
commented
let's try it out
those are my three australian greetings
and if the country is france
bonjour commented
however if i enter something which isn't
france and isn't australia
nothing
let's include another elsif
else if country equals japan konichiwa
chelsea
i think i pronounced that correctly
let's try it out now
and there are my japanese messages
i can have as many else if clauses as i
like in a block if statement
and i can finish with a single else
clause
if i don't type australia france or
japan
then it will say hello there i hope you
are well
so everybody gets something
now just a small word of warning
the tests that you perform with an if
statement
are case sensitive
watch what happens if i type australia
in lower case
the block of code in the else clause is
executing
because i didn't use a capital a
i can remove the case sensitivity of
this test by converting the contents of
the variable st country into uppercase
like this
i'm saying take the content of st
country convert it to uppercase
and then put the uppercase version of it
back into the variable overwriting the
original contents of that variable
and now i'm going to check to see if
that is equal to this
it doesn't matter what type of case i
use when i'm typing in the country
i've removed the case sensitivity from
the test
let's just step through this to be sure
what's going on
i'll put a break point on the procedure
so i've typed in lowercase australia
that's what i've captured into this
variable
and then i've converted it to uppercase
australia
so i'm asking if uppercase australia is
equal to uppercase australia
and notice how execution has passed to
the end of the if block
because the australian greetings have
been displayed there's no need to
perform these other tests
one final thing to say i've converted
the user's input into uppercase and i
might not want to leave it in
uppercase notice this
once the if block has completed any code
which comes after it then executes for
example this message box statement but
notice that st country now contains
uppercase japan i might want to leave it
the way it was when it was input by the
user
so rather than doing this which replaces
the existing contents of the variable
i'm going to do this
the content of the variable
is only being converted to uppercase for
the purpose of the test but i'm not
reassigning the uppercase text back into
the variable i'm converting the text to
uppercase on the fly as it were
watch what happens now
by the time we get to the end of the
program the contents of the variable are
still in their original state
you might like to try writing a similar
program yourself have a single if block
with lots of else if clauses to greet
people from different countries
in the previous video of this series i
showed you how to use an if block to
execute a block of code conditionally in
other words to decide whether or not to
execute a block of code
the if block allows you to use one of
the three constructs of high-level
programming languages
namely selection
in this video i want to say more about
the if block and the kind of tests that
we can perform with an if block
i've already created a new windows forms
application and i've put three controls
on the form i have a label a text box
and a button
notice that i've named the text box txt
exam score
and i've named the button
btn get grade
the idea is that the user of this
application will type in an exam score
and then the program will calculate the
grade
let's write the code and see how we can
use logical operators to build complex
conditions
i'll start by capturing the score into a
variable
i'm assigning the contents of the text
box to an integer variable called i
score
now the first thing i want to do is
check whether it's a valid score
let's suppose that you can only score
between 0 and 100 on this test
there's a few things to notice here
i'm asking if the score is less than
zero this is the less than symbol
and let me be clear less than zero means
minus one minus two minus three
zero is not actually less than zero zero
is equal to zero
i'm also checking to see if the score is
bigger than one hundred
given that you can't score more than one
hundred on this particular exam anything
bigger than one hundred would be invalid
if the score is less than zero or the
score is greater than 100 then we'll
display a message saying this is not a
valid score
i'm also giving the user of my
application some guidance i'm not just
telling them what they did was wrong i'm
telling them what they should do instead
which is good practice for an error
message
then notice i'm exiting the program
i've put another line of code here just
to prove the point
when we drop out of the if block
normally this line of code would be
executed
but because i've said exit sub this will
force the program to stop there and then
let's give it a try
if i type a score of let's say -1
this is not a valid score i'm getting
the error message
let's try a score of 101.
again not a valid score let's try a
score of 99
and i want you to notice that we've
dropped out of the if block and we're
getting that message at the end of the
program saying all done it hasn't
actually done anything yet we'll deal
with that in a moment
just to be sure
i should really test the value zero
zero is valid zero is a perfectly good
value and i should also test the value
100
and that's fine as well
so that's the beginning of my exam
checker program and i'm using something
called a logical operator
the word or is one of three logical
operators which you'll come across
the less than symbol
and the greater than symbol are called
relational operators
that is the condition clause of my if
statement and because it's effectively
performing more than one test we call it
a complex condition
now before i try and work out what the
grade for a particular score is i'm
going to keep it really simple and just
test to see whether somebody has passed
or failed
so if the score is bigger than or equal
to 50 it's a pass
if the score is less than 50 it's a fail
notice the greater than or equal to
symbol that's another relational
operator
let's give it a whirl
a score of 45
is a fail
and notice all done is being displayed
unconditionally
that's going to happen one way or the
other
a score of 55 is a pass
now it's good practice when you're
testing a program like this to try all
of the boundary values and by boundary
values i mean 50 is a boundary
100 is a boundary zero is a boundary
so let's try a score of 50.
50 is a pass
it's also a good idea to test parts of
the program that we've already tested
because when you add new code you might
introduce bugs
so i'm going to test less than zero
again
minus five is not valid
and neither is 105
it seems to be working
now you might have already noticed that
i've used three
separate if blocks
in the previous video i showed you one
if block with multiple else if clauses
and i'd like to point out the difference
between the two
i'm going to set a breakpoint on this
program and run it up again
and we'll put in a failing score
let's say
30
and now i'll step through the code
so we assign the contents of the text
box to the variable
we check to see if the contents of the
variable are within range in this case
they are so we jump to the end of this
if block
then we check to see if the score is
greater than or equal to 50 which it
isn't
so we jump to the end of this if block
and then finally we check to see if the
score is less than 50 which it is
and we report that it's a fail
all done
let's do that again but this time i'm
going to put in a passing score
let's say 75
assign the content of the text box to
the variable check that it's in range
which of course it is so we jump to the
end of the first if block
check to see if the score is bigger than
or equal to 50 which it is
report that it's a pass
and now we're checking to see if the
score is less than 50 which of course is
unnecessary we're doing a test that we
don't need to do we've already
established that it's a pass
to make my program more efficient
i'm going to use a single if block
with multiple else ifs
my validation test where i checked to
see that the score was actually within
range i could have left as a completely
separate if block but don't forget there
was an exit sub in there and it may well
be that there's some code i want to
execute unconditionally at the bottom of
the program
if you use exit sub early on that won't
happen
so i've included this as well inside the
if block with multiple lcif's let's give
it a go
a score of 67 is a pass all done let's
step through it and watch what's
happening
the score is in range
the score is bigger than or equal to 50
so we report a
pass and then we drop out of the if
block we don't need to do any more tests
so although it's perfectly reasonable to
have multiple if blocks each performing
a separate test
it may be better to use a single if
block with multiple else ifs and then
the program doesn't have to work as hard
now admittedly with a little program
like this i'm not going to notice a lot
of difference but as you start writing
longer more complex programs then small
adjustments will add up and your program
will run faster
okay it's one thing writing a program
that works efficiently
but it also has to be robust we want a
program that you can't crash and i can
crash this one easily watch
i'm typing text into the text box rather
than a number
invalid cast exception conversion from
string 10 to type integer is not valid
this makes the point that when you type
something into a text box it's a string
there's the word ten with double quotes
around it
and i'm trying to put that string into a
variable that's designed to hold
integers whole numbers
i'll run the program again with a
breakpoint but this time i'll be a
well-behaved user
notice that the text box contains the
string 1-0
the text box does not contain a number
it's a string of characters but because
i'm trying to assign it to an integer
variable vb will attempt to convert it
into an integer and the string 1 0 can
be converted into the number 10 so
everything is fine
the program does not crash
the text 1 0 in double quotes has been
converted into the number 10.
converting data from one type to another
is called casting and vb was able to do
the cast
let's run it again with something it
can't handle
vb will attempt to convert the string
five into a number and of course
that is an invalid cast it can't do it
the last thing i want to do is give my
program to a user who can inadvertently
crash it
so let's add some extra code to get
around this problem
before i attempt to initialize the
variable i score with the contents of
the text box i'm going to test to see
whether or not vb will be able to
convert it into a number
like this
is numeric is a special built-in
function which will allow me to test
whether or not something can be
converted into a number in this case i'm
testing the contents of the text box
let me be clear it doesn't convert it
into a number it simply asks the
question can it be converted into a
number
when i perform this test the outcome
will either be true if it can be
converted or false if it can't so i'm
saying if is numeric equals true if it
can be converted into a number then
i will do this line of code i'm
initializing the variable conditionally
if it can't be converted then i give an
appropriate error message and i am
exiting the program this time because
there isn't much i can do with that data
unless it is actually a number
so there's my little validation routine
let's give it a go
in some text
you must enter a number
and i'm not getting the all done message
because i've forced an exit from the
program
now there's one more thing i can do
just to improve the efficiency of the
program a little bit and that's to tell
vp that i want to convert the contents
of the text box into an integer rather
than allowing vb to make the decision
for me and i can do it like this
c int is short for convert to integer
and of course my program is only going
to do this if it can i've already made
sure of that with my is numeric test
if i left this out it would still work
but i'm leaving it up to vb to decide
what to convert the contents of the text
box into an integer a double a single
and it will make that decision based on
the variables data type
i'm just taking the decision out of vb's
hands and it will result in a very
slight improvement in performance
i'll talk more about special inbuilt
functions in another video but you've
seen two already is numeric and c int
in the previous video i showed you how
to write this little routine to check if
an exam score was a passing score or a
failing score
i made use of one of three logical
operators i used the or operator
in this video i want to say a little bit
about the other two logical operators
namely and
and not
i'll be adding more else if clauses to
my if block to come up with a grade for
a particular score rather than just pass
or fail
in the previous video i also paid
particular attention to validating the
user's input
you can see my program has an if block
right at the start to check if the
user's input can be converted into a
number and if it can then it does it
converts it into an integer
i've explicitly performed the type
conversion also known as a cast using
the c inter function
if i hadn't used c int then v b would
have done the cast for me if it could
if v b does it it's known as implicit
type conversion
explicit type conversion is more
efficient
before we add some more logic to this
program i just want to point out that
it's not perfectly robust yet
i can still crash this let me show you
how
you've seen that if i type text i've
essentially trapped the error but what
if i put in a number which is too big
that is an extremely large number
and it's crashed my program
an integer variable occupies four bytes
of memory that is 32 bits
so the maximum number of values that you
can store in an integer variable is 2 to
the power 32
it works out to about 4 billion
now since we also need to store negative
integers that means we can go from about
minus 2 billion to positive 2 billion
the number i entered was bigger than 2
billion and i've got what's known as an
overflow exception
there's a possibility that the person
who's using my program might type in a
very large number and trigger this
runtime error
this is a fairly easy one to sort out
i'm just going to change the user
interface
notice that my text box has a max length
property that's the maximum number of
characters i can type into the text box
you can see it's over 32 000. i can type
32
767 characters into this text box well
my exam score is never going to be
bigger than let's say a hundred so if i
limit the number of characters that you
can type into the text box to let's say
three then the maximum value you can put
in there is 999 a simple fix
i can't enter a number bigger than three
characters long
now let's add some more logic to the if
block
depending on the score i want to award a
grade which is either a b c d e or f
i'm going to keep the test which checks
to see if the data is within range but
i'll add some more else if clauses
if you score less than or equal to 20
that is a grade f
if you score more than 20
and less than or equal to 30 that is a
grade e
notice the use of the logical operator
and what i'm saying is the score must be
bigger than 20
and it must also be less than or equal
to 30.
a score between 31 and 40 will get you a
d
and anything between 41 and 50 we'll
call that a c
in this particular examination anything
between 51 and 70 will get you a b
notice i've got a syntax error there's a
red wavy line what's it telling me
expression expected not particularly
helpful
but this is actually quite a common
mistake when you're writing complex
expressions which include logical and
relational operators
i need to include i score again right
here
if i'm using a relational operator to
compare two things such as a variable
and a number then i have to say what two
things i am comparing i have to be
explicit
okay so every other school is going to
get you a grade a so i can just use an
else clause now
and that is all of the possibilities
taken care of now notice i've been very
very careful not to overlap the ranges
of scores
this range is between 21 and 30
inclusive
this range is between 31 and 40
inclusive there's no overlap
if for example i made this mistake
and i said greater than or equal to 30
then a score of 30 falls into this range
and it falls into this range then my
program might not work i might get some
peculiar results so just be very careful
about that
if you think about what's going on here
a score of 30 is not covered either by
this test or by this test think it
through and you'll see that a score of
30 will actually get you a grade a
but that should be fine
there's one more logical operator which
i haven't mentioned and to be honest i
don't really need it in this scenario
but i can make use of it just to
illustrate how it works
instead of asking if the score is out of
range
i'm going to just turn the logic of that
question around and ask if the score is
not in range
in a sense it's the same question if the
score is not in between one and a
hundred then it must be out of range
now all that remains is to test the
program thoroughly
there are several possible execution
paths and i should really test them all
i should also make a point of testing
things which i've tested before for
example my validation routine here
i need to make sure that i haven't
introduced any bugs when i added new
functionality
this is called regression testing
i should also check all of the boundary
values i should try a value of 0 a value
of 100 a value of 20 30 40 70 and i
should also try valid values within the
ranges which i've specified in my if
statement namely 25 35 45 60 75.
if you don't test thoroughly and then
you start adding more code to this then
you're building on shifting sand
do it carefully now and you'll save
yourself a lot more work later on
and straight away i found a problem it
is possible to score zero on an exam
that should have been greater than or
equal to zero
that's better
as i said make sure that you test every
possible pathway through the program
i'm going to show you an alternative to
the if block
another way to perform selection in your
code
i've created a new project let's pop a
text box on there to capture some input
and a button to run my program
the idea is that the user types in the
temperature maybe 15 degrees and then
the check temperature button will tell
the user whether it's cold freezing warm
hot that kind of thing
and although i could allow vb to do the
implicit type conversion for me i'm
going to do it explicitly
remember a text box captures text input
i'm converting it into an integer
i'm not going to worry about my program
crashing if the user doesn't behave
themselves and type in a number
now this is what the select case
construct looks like
it begins with the word select
case and then the name of the variable
which i want to test
in this case i temperature
and it finishes with end select
and now i'm going to say in case i
temperature is
equal to zero
i will output the message freezing
if the temperature is less than zero i'm
going to output an appropriate message
for that as well
if the temperature is between 1 and 10
that's cold
notice the syntax case 1 2 10 that means
everything between 1 and 10 inclusive so
1 and 10 are included as well
if it's between 11 and 20 it's warm
and let's say everything else is hot
and there it is the select case
construct
now i could have done exactly the same
thing using an if block but arguably
this is a little easier to read it's
somewhat easier to see what's going on
by the way i could execute multiple
lines of code as a result of each test
okay it's a bit silly but you get the
point
i'm selecting one block of code or
another depending on the outcome of a
test
let's give it a try
minus five is sub zero
zero is freezing
water will freeze and you can go skating
hate is cold
15 is warm
and 200 is hot
you should really test all of the
boundaries as well so you should see
what happens if you enter a 1 or a 10 or
11 20 and then something incredibly big
this program can be crashed as well
because we could type in some text but
of course we could add some additional
logic to validate the data before the
code gets into the select case block
by the way there are some other things i
can use in a case statement for example
i could say case 1 comma two comma three
comma four five
and that's an alternative to saying one
to ten
so if it isn't a continuous range of
values which i'm testing that would be
the way to go
and i can use all of my relational
operators when i'm composing a test as
well so for example here i've used a
less than sign but i could use greater
than i could use less than or equal to
greater than or equal to not equal to
the same as if i was building a test for
an if block
now you might be wondering why bother
with an if block at all why not use
select case every time
well there is a particular limitation
when it comes to select case you can
only test one variable at a time
let's say for example we've also
captured the wind speed
i've just hard coded a value for the
purpose of demonstration
i can't do something like this with a
select case construct
i'm testing the contents of two
variables using a logical operator
with a select case construct i can only
test one variable at a time
i could however nest an if block inside
the select case construct something like
this
so if the temperature is less than zero
we'll report that it is sub-zero and
then we'll check the wind speed and if
the wind speed is bigger than 20 we'll
report that it's going to feel really
cold
you'd like to give it a try yourself
maybe rewrite the exam grading program
to use a select case construct instead
of an if block
by the way
different programming languages might
well have their own equivalent to the
select case construct
c sharp for example uses the switch
construct but it does pretty much the
same thing
if you see pseudo code on an exam paper
it may well be written like this i've
commented it out because it won't work
in visual basic but you can see the
concept is pretty much the same
i'm going to show you the third of the
three fundamental constructs of high
level programming
namely iteration
it's iteration means executing a block
of code repeatedly
iteration is also known as looping and
there are two ways you can do this in
vb.net
one of them is with a for loop and the
other is with a do loop
in this video i'm going to focus on the
for loop
i've already created a new windows forms
application and i've placed a button on
the form so let's get right into the
code
to make something execute repeatedly i
need a way to count the number of
repetitions i need a way to count the
number of iterations so i'm going to
declare a variable of type integer
it doesn't really matter what i call the
variable i've called it i count because
i'm going to count my way through a loop
the for loop looks like this
any code that i write between for and
next will execute repeatedly in this
case five times because i'm counting
from one to five let's begin with a
simple message
give it a try
hello once
twice
three times
four times
five times
now that was a single line of code but
let's put a couple more inside the loop
try it again
hello how are you well i hope once
hello how are you well i hope twice
so these three lines of code are
executing in sequence
five times
let's take it back down to one line for
now
i can display the value of i count as
part of the message like this
hello1 hello2 3
4
5.
let's do something a little more
interesting my program will beep every
time we pass through the loop
the beep command is very straightforward
threading.thread.sleep
means pause for three seconds
something nice about a looping construct
such as the for loop is i can change the
number of iterations as easily as this
the code inside the loop will now
execute 50 times i can also change the
step value like this
so i'm going to count up from one to
fifty five at a time
perhaps it makes more sense to count
from zero
i can also count backwards
in this case i'm counting from 50 to
zero and i'm stepping minus five at a
time
if i want to display the output in a
single message box rather than separate
message boxes i could do something like
this
inside the loop i'm not doing any output
i'm simply building the output string
i'm saying let st out equal whatever it
used to be
and then something else in this case the
value of i count along with a new line
operator
this time i only have one message box
outside of the loop
and that's quite a common technique
so there it is the for loop
in the next video we'll look at the do
loop
and then following that you'll see how
the looping constructs really come into
their own when working with array
variables
before we move on and look at another
iteration construct i thought it would
be a good idea to get some practice in
with what you've already learned
i've written a program here which makes
use of an if block and a couple of for
loops
i'll show you what it does first then
you can pause the video and try to write
it yourself
when you're ready you can look at my
solution
my button has the text count up od or
even because that's what it does let's
see
first i'm asked what number do you want
to count up to i'd like to count up to
10.
then i'm asked do you want odd numbers
or even numbers
notice i'm using an input box here
you've seen this in an earlier video
i want
the even numbers
and my program comes back with 2
4
6
8
10.
let's run it again
what number do you want to count up to i
can choose any number i like i'll go
with 10 again
odd or even numbers let's try the odd
numbers this time
1
3
5
7
nine
and that's it let's just give it one
more try
let's count up to 20.
odd or even let's go with odd again
so that's the idea
if you want to try writing this program
yourself pause the video now and give it
a go and then you can resume the video
when you're ready to see my solution
i should say there's no one way to solve
this problem
and here's my solution
i've declared a variable called imax
which is the number the program will
count up to
it's an integer variable
i've declared a string variable called
st odor even which will store order or
even depending on what the user types in
and then i have another variable called
x which will be my loop counter
it'll control passage through the count
controlled loops
i start by asking the user what number
they would like to count up to that
value gets assigned to imax then i ask
the user do you want odd numbers or even
numbers and that gets assigned to st odd
or even
i now have an if block where i'm testing
the value of st odd or even if the user
typed in even
then we have a for loop which will count
up in even numbers
notice that i'm starting from two
and counting up to imax and i'm using
the step clause to say that i want to
step two at a time so that's going to
give me the even numbers up to the
number that the user types in
else if st odd or even is equal to odd
then i have a for loop which starts at
one
runs to imax but also steps two at a
time so we start with one then we add
two then we add two and so on
as i said this is just my solution you
might have come up with something
slightly different for example you might
have used two separate if statements
like this
and that's fine because it will work
having said that using a single if block
with an else if clause is a little bit
more efficient because this program will
have to perform both tests
did you get something similar
did yours work if not why not try my
approach
you previously saw how to make a line of
code or indeed a block of code execute
repeatedly using a for next loop like
this one here
i'm using a variable which i've named x
to count my way through the loop let's
just remind ourselves what it does
personally i tend to avoid using letters
of the alphabet for variable names i
like the names to be a little bit more
meaningful so i'm going to rename x to
something a little more appropriate
i've called it i count instead
i because it's an integer and count
because that's what it's for it's to
count my way through the loop
in this video i want to show you an
alternative way to make a line of code
or a block of code execute repeatedly
i'm going to show you something called
the do while loop
i'm referring to it as the do while loop
because most people do but as you'll see
in a moment it comes in a number of
different forms
here's one of them
now you might be tempted to give this a
try as it stands i strongly recommend
that whenever you're writing code that
contains looping constructs you should
always save your code first
watch what happens when i run this
hello hello
this will go on forever just saying
hello zero let's see if we can work out
why
i need to stop the program fortunately i
can still see this red square
here so that will force the execution to
stop
i've said that i want the loop to repeat
while the value of i count is less than
or equal to
five immediately after you've declared a
numeric variable it will contain zero
so by the time we get to this line of
code i count contains the value zero
which of course is less than or equal to
five
so we output hello zero
when the loop repeats i count is still
zero its value hasn't changed so we
output the message again
and then the loop repeats again and
again and again it's called an infinite
loop
it will go on forever
because i'm using a do while loop i need
to make sure that i write some code to
increment the value of i count
i'm going to increment the value of i
count before i do the output like this
so all this line of code says is take
the value of i count add one to it and
then put the result back into high count
overwriting what's already there in
other words add one to i count
so at the top of the loop we check if
the value of i count is less than or
equal to five which first time around it
is it's equal to zero
then we increment it so now i count has
the value one
then we do the output hello one
we go back to the top of the loop and
because i count is still less than or
equal to five we get back into the loop
code and we add one to it
highcount now has a value of two so we
can output hello2
and around and around we go until such
time as i count is no longer less than
or equal to five
we've met the so-called exit condition
of the loop
so we can exit the loop and the program
will continue
down here let's just put a line of code
in here just to prove that the program
has dropped out of the loop
now let's give it a go
hello one
two
three four five
six
we'll have to look at that and think
about why that's happening
and then all done
i only wanted to count up to five but it
actually counted up to six and that has
to do with the exit condition of my loop
i said i want to loop while i count is
less than or equal to five which means
my loop will continue if i count is
equal to five
when i count is equal to five i add one
to it so it becomes six and i do another
output
all i need to change
is that exit condition
do while i count is less than five
that's
better you need to be mindful of the
contents of the variable which you are
using to count your way through the loop
now you might be wondering why do we
bother with do while loops when we have
four next loops i've had to write more
code to get the same effect
the answer to that question is that the
do while loop is more flexible
for example i can say do until
i count is equal to five
strictly speaking this is not a do while
loop this is a do until loop
watch what happens when i run it
exactly the same effect
but it means that i can build an
alternative exit condition for a loop
and as you'll see later sometimes it's
more appropriate to use do until rather
than do while
i can also do this
i'm just going to move this piece of
code
so i'm saying do
this block of code and loop until i
count is equal to five
let's take a look
exactly the same effect
but sometimes it's appropriate to put
the exit condition at the bottom of the
loop
this means that the code inside the loop
will execute at least once
if the exit condition is at the top of
the loop it might not execute at all
if for example something has set the
value of i count to be equal to 5 before
we go into the loop like this
then the code inside the loop won't
execute at all we've already met the
exit condition
and there's one more form of the do
while loop if i may call it that which
i'd like to show you
loop while i count is less than five
does the same thing let's look at those
four variations next to each other so we
can compare them
for loops that do exactly the same thing
now we need to be careful here i need to
re-initialize the value of i count in
between each of these loops
it starts off here with a value of zero
but by the time we've dropped out of the
first loop it will have a value of five
as i said you need to be mindful of the
value inside the variable which you are
using to count your way through the loop
for good practice i'm going to
explicitly initialize it here as well
although i know in this particular
program it will have a value of 0 at
that point
so there you have it
four different variations of the do
while loop or the do until loop if you'd
rather call it that
i'm going to show you a useful
application of a do while loop
i want the user to enter a number and
only a number a do loop can be used to
repeatedly prompt the user if the data
is invalid
i'm also going to show you why a do loop
is called a condition controlled loop
you might remember that a for next loop
is called a count controlled loop
let's write some code
let me show you something which might
strike you as rather silly but it makes
a very important point
i'm using an input box function to
prompt the user to type in their name
but the name must be kevin so i've
placed this instruction inside a do
while loop and look at my exit condition
do while st name is not equal to kevin
when we drop out of the loop i simply
output the name that was entered
let's give it a try
i'll try john
that's no good ben
nope
enzo
anything i type is invalid unless
it's kevin
you can see why this is called a
condition controlled loop rather than a
count controlled loop
i'm not incrementing a variable to
determine how many times i pass through
the loop
there's no loop counter involved
let me show you another approach
do while true
equals true
i could have just as easily said do
while one is equal to one
that might strike you as a rather
ridiculous exit condition because one
always equals one essentially what i've
written here is an infinite loop
true equals true is more
typical in fact i can just say do while
true it means exactly the same thing
but if i have an infinite loop well how
do i get out of it
i can do this
i capture the input test it to see if
it's what i'm looking for and if it is
then i force an exit from the do loop by
using the command exit do
once again you can see that i'm not
counting my way through the loop i'm
exiting the loop in a different way
so how is all of this useful well as i
said i want to write a program to prompt
the user to enter a number and only a
number take a look at this
i've declared two variables
one called sth
because i want to capture the user's age
but notice i've declared it as a string
and then i've declared another variable
called i age which is an integer
i'm prompting the user to enter their
age
and i'm assigning the value to sth
this is a temporary measure so that i
can test sth
and look at my exit condition
do while is numeric sth equals false
in other words while whatever the user
types in cannot be converted into a
number
to understand this you need to
appreciate that the input box function
always captures a string
so for example if i'm prompted to type a
number and i type let's say 59 i'm
actually typing the string
five nine
if i attempt to assign that string to a
numeric variable like i age it'll be
fine visual basic will do something
called implicit type conversion it will
automatically convert it into an integer
because it can for example this line of
code
will be absolutely fine as long as the
user types in a string that can be
converted into an integer
if however when this line of code
executes the user types in a string like
hello it will crash the program because
visual basic can't automatically convert
that string into something we can save
into an integer variable
i'm trying to prevent my program
crashing for that reason
so instead i'm asking the user to type
in their age but i'm storing it into a
string variable it doesn't matter what
they type when we assign it to a string
variable it'll work
but because i want a number i keep
asking the user to type something until
such time as i can convert it into a
number and that's what is numeric is
telling me whether or not a variable's
contents can be converted into a number
i could ask the same question in a
slightly different way like this for
example
do while is numeric is not equal to true
it means the same thing as do while is
numeric equals false i can even ask the
question like this
do while not is numeric
it's the same exit condition just
phrased in a different way
i'm using a logical operator this time
instead of a relational operator
it really is a case of take your pick
so we are repeatedly prompting the user
to type in something we can convert into
a number and when the user finally types
in something that we can convert into a
number
we do so
i'm using one of the type conversion
functions this time c int that's short
for convert to integer so i'm converting
this string into an integer and i know
that this line of code is not going to
crash because we wouldn't have got this
far in the program unless the user typed
in something that i could convert
this is called explicit type conversion
it's also called casting when we change
the data from one data type to another
let's give it a try
i'll start with some text
that's invalid so i'm being prompted
again let's try some different text
again i didn't type something which can
be converted into a number so the loop
continues
let's try typing nothing at all
i'll just click ok
well that's no good either because
that's what we call a zero length string
think of a pair of quotes with nothing
in between
if i press the cancel button
again that's invalid
i can't get out of this until i type
something that can be converted into a
number
remember that might look like 123
but it's actually the string one two
three
but it's a string that can be converted
into a number
so we drop out of the loop convert the
input into a number store it in ih and
then display it in the message box
so there you go a condition controlled
do while loop which i'm using to capture
input and validate it at the same time
in this video i'm going to talk about
array variables
as you'll see array variables are
particularly useful when you want to
store a large number of related data
items
in fact once you've learned about array
variables you'll be able to write some
very very useful programs
before i begin let's quickly review
what's going on inside the computer's
memory when we use regular variables
when this line of code executes the
operating system will set aside a piece
of memory and it will give it the name s
t fruit
the exact location of this piece of
memory is entirely up to the operating
system it doesn't really concern us as
programmers
but suffice to say no other program can
use that piece of memory it belongs to
this program
immediately after a string variable has
been declared it will contain something
it contains a zero length string think
of a pair of double quotes with nothing
in between them
if you declare a numeric variable for
example an integer then immediately
after declaration it will contain the
value zero
for the purposes of this discussion we
don't really need to worry about this
zero length string
when this line of code executes
i'm assigning a value to the variable
i'm putting the text banana in there
when i output the contents of a variable
it doesn't change the contents of the
variable we're simply taking a copy of
what's in the variable and then
displaying it on the screen
my variable still contains the text
banana
this line of code will overwrite the
existing contents of the variable we're
replacing the text banana with the text
orange
the original contents of the variable
are now lost
when this line of code executes
a separate piece of memory is being set
aside
this time the piece of memory is called
st fruit 2. no prizes for guessing what
that's going to be storing
the exact location of this second
variable again depends on the operating
system
one of the main functions of the
operating system in my case windows 10
is to manage the memory
this line of code assigns the string
pineapple to st fruit 2.
when this line of code executes a copy
of the contents of st fruit are assigned
to st fruit 2.
so orange overwrites pineapple
by the time we get to the final message
box statement both variables contain the
same thing
now
let's talk about
array variables
suppose that i want to store and process
several different items of fruit
i could do it like this
i've declared five separate variables
and i've initialized them individually
if i want to output the contents of one
of those variables that's
straightforward enough as long as i know
the name of the variable
that will output pineapple
but using regular variables like this to
store a group of related data items is
actually quite cumbersome what if i
wanted to store 10 items of fruit or
even 100 items of fruit
i'm going to end up with rather a lot of
code
instead of using five separate string
variables i'm going to use one array
variable like this
i've used quite a lot of copying and
pasting to speed things up
i'm also going to change the name of
this variable just to indicate that it
is actually an array variable i'm going
to prefix the name with hey
a because it's an array
st because it's an array of strings and
fruits because well that's what these
are
you could actually call your array
anything you like but as you write more
code you'll see the benefits of a naming
convention
to understand what's going on here again
we should visualize what's going on
inside the computer's memory when i
declare an array variable like this i'm
actually saying that i want to set aside
a group
of memory locations
to be more precise i'm setting aside a
group of contiguous memory locations
contiguous means adjacent next to each
other
the number four means that i want a
group of five memory locations
it might strike you as odd but in
computer science we generally count from
zero we say that the array is zero based
each location in that group of memory
locations is referred to as an element
so i have five elements numbered from
zero to four
when this line of code executes i'm
putting the text banana into element
zero
this line of code puts orange into
element one
pineapple into element two strawberry
into element three and mango goes into
element number four
i'm referring to each element by its
index number
when i want to reference one of those
data items again i use the index number
so in this case i'm outputting the
contents of ast fruits 2 element number
2
pineapple
let's give it a try
as expected
let's output orange i just have to
change the two to a one
if i want to output mango i'll type a
four here
i can also reference an element of an
array less directly let's declare an
integer variable
i'm just giving it the name i
i'm going to assign a value to that
variable
and now i'm going to use the contents of
i to reference an element of the array
can you see what the program will output
this time
i is equal to 3
so this reads as ast fruits 3
it will output strawberry
indeed it does
let's change the value of i to 0.
now i'm out putting banana
banana is the zeroth element of the
array
we can run into trouble though watch
this
i'm setting the value of i to be equal
to eight
my array variable only has five elements
numbered from zero to four there is no
element number eight
so what happens when i run the program
now
index out of range exception
my program has crashed it's crashed
because it can't find element number
eight there's no such thing
let's reset the program
now there's one more thing i would like
to show you
which is where the real power of array
variables comes in
i want to output each of those items in
turn
so i am going to iterate through the
array using a for next loop
watch this
for i equals naught to four output ast
fruits i
first time through the loop i is equal
to zero so this
will output banana
second time through the loop i will be
equal to one so we output orange then i
is incremented to two and we output
pineapple and so on until such time as i
equals four
let's give it a try
and you can imagine i can iterate
through a hundred array elements
just as easily as i can iterate through
five
give this a try yourself
perhaps you can set up an array with ten
elements instead of five
in this video i'm going to invite you to
practice what you've already learned
there are eight exercises here involving
array variables and loops which you
might like to try coding up yourself
i'll show you what they do and then it's
up to you if you want to give them a go
alternatively you can jump straight to
my solutions later on in this video
by the way all of these programs start
with the same six lines of code
all of them declare an array variable of
integers with five elements
and then the array is initialized as you
can see here
but it's important to realize that your
programs have to work with any data not
just these
so let's see what they do
the first exercise is to output each
item in a separate message box one after
another well you've already seen how to
do this in a previous video
i'm using a loop to scan through the
array
exercise 2 output all of the items in
the same message box but on separate
lines
exercise three is to add up all of the
items and output the total in a message
box
they add up to seventy five
in exercise four we calculate the
average of the items
the average value is fifteen
very similar to exercise three except
we're dividing the total by the number
of items
in exercise five we are only adding up
the items that are bigger than twenty
there are two items in the array which
are bigger than twenty namely thirty
three and twenty two and they add up to
fifty five
we're still doing this with a loop but
as we visit each item we're deciding
whether it's bigger than 20 or not
in exercise six this is a little bit
trickier you have to find the largest
item and output it in a message box
the biggest item is thirty three
and let's be clear the program is
working out which is the biggest item
if you can do exercise six you'll find
exercise 7 very easy exercise 7 is
finding the smallest item
and exercise 8 is replacing each item in
the array with a new value that is twice
as big
and then we output those values in
pretty much the same way as we did in
exercise two
so if you want to give them a try
yourself pause the video now and see
what you can come up with alternatively
you can jump straight to the solutions
so let's take a look at my solutions
the objective of exercise one was to
output each item in a separate message
box one after another
you've seen how to do this in a previous
video i start by declaring an array of
five integers and then i initialize the
array
in order to scan the array i need a loop
counter so i've declared an integer
variable called i and that controls the
number of passes through the for loop
then i say for i equals naught to 4
output ai data
element number i
so first time through the loop i is zero
that outputs the first item second time
i is one i output the second item and so
on until i is equal to four we output
the last item and we drop out of the
loop
in exercise 2 we want to output all of
the items in the same message box
so we don't have an output command
within the loop we're simply building a
string
i've declared a string variable called
st out and inside the loop i say st out
equals whatever it used to be plus the
next item in the array
i'm also concatenating a new line
operator on there as well so the string
actually contains the information needed
to throw a new line between each item
when we drop out of the loop we display
the output string in one go
the solution to exercise 3 is similar to
the solution to exercise 2.
we want to calculate the total of the
data items so i've declared a variable
called i total to contain this
and then as we visit each item in the
loop i say i total equals whatever it
used to be
plus
the next item
i'm using the addition operator instead
of the concatenation operator this time
when we drop out of the loop i display
the total
in one message
the objective of exercise 4 was to
calculate the average well this is
pretty much the same as the previous
exercise i calculate the total first
and then when i display the message i
simply divide the total by five
with exercise five the objective was to
add up all of the items bigger than 20.
so in some ways it's similar to the
previous program i've declared a
variable to hold the total
but look what's going on inside the for
loop
i'm adding the next value to the total
conditionally
i'm testing each value first to see if
it's bigger than 20 and if it is i add
it to the total if it isn't well i don't
if you think about it adding up all of
the items which are let's say smaller
than 20 would require a very simple
change all i'd need to do is change this
relational operator to a less than sign
in exercise 6 you were invited to write
a program to find the largest item in
the array
the principle behind this program is to
visit each item in the array and if it's
bigger than the previous item then keep
a record of it so i've declared a
variable called imax which will hold the
maximum value and i've initialized it to
zero which pretty much guarantees that
everything is going to be bigger than
imax to begin with
assuming i'm only working with positive
numbers
when i visit the first item inside my
loop i ask is it bigger than i max
well of course item zero the number five
is bigger than imax it's bigger than
zero
so i'm assigning the first item to imax
overwriting its previous value
imax now contains a five five is the
biggest item we've found so far
second time through the loop i examine
the second item and i ask is it bigger
than imax in this case well seven is
bigger than five so i replace five with
seven
i'm keeping track of the biggest item
third time through the loop same
question and i replace seven with 33
but fourth time through the loop i find
that 22 is not bigger than 33
so this line of code doesn't execute
by the time the program's finished imax
contains the biggest value
if you can solve exercise 6 then you can
solve exercise 7 very very easily
this time i have a variable called i min
which is going to hold the minimum value
and i'm initializing it with a very
large value something that i know is
bigger than anything else in the array
i've made it ten thousand
when i visit the first item i ask is it
smaller than i min well of course it is
5 is smaller than 10 000.
so i min becomes the first value and
then we proceed pretty much as we did in
the previous program by the time we drop
out of the loop we have the smallest
value
the objective of exercise eight was to
replace each item in the array with a
new value twice as big
i actually want to change the contents
of the array and that's what this loop
does
it's actually very simple
i say let a i data the item i'm looking
at be equal to itself
multiplied by two
so by the time we drop out of this loop
the array contains a completely
different set of data
and then the remaining code simply
outputs those data in a single message
box just like in exercise two
now even if you didn't solve these
problems yourself it's well worth trying
to duplicate the code that you can see
here it will definitely help you get a
feel for using array variables with
loops
in this video i'm going to show you how
to implement a linear search
a linear search is one of many standard
algorithms that you'll come across as a
programmer
the principle of a linear search is to
examine a list of items one at a time to
see if it contains an item that we're
looking for
i've already declared an array of ten
strings and you can see i've initialized
it with various items of fruit
by the way you can see that the program
contains the data that we're going to
search we say that the data has been
hard coded into the program
this is untypical in reality a program
wouldn't normally have the data written
into it like this
you'll see in later videos that a
program can actually read the data in
from an external file perhaps a database
or a text file or a spreadsheet or even
a web page
you'll also see how one program can call
another and pass it some data to work
with
for the purposes of demonstrating a
linear search hard coding the data like
this is absolutely fine
we'll start by prompting the user for an
item to search for we'll call it the
target value
so i've declared a variable to store it
and to keep things simple i'll use an
input box to prompt the user
now i'm going to use a loop to scan
through the array to visit each item one
at a time
i'll need a loop counter
and i'm going to use a for loop i could
use a do loop it's a matter of
preference a for loop will mean i can
write slightly less code
as i visit each item i'm going to check
to see if it's the target value i can do
this with an if statement
now this isn't the finished product but
it's well on the way let's see what
happens
i'm getting a message for every item
which is not the one i'm searching for
but i did get a message saying it found
it
let's try it again
i'm looking for a star fruit this time
there is no star fruit in the list
well it's on the way but i don't want a
message for every item which isn't the
one i'm looking for
so let's improve it
rather than doing some output inside the
loop
i'm simply going to keep a record of
whether or not i found it
and to do this i'm going to use a
boolean variable
a boolean variable can have one of two
possible values true or false
immediately after it's been declared
it'll have a value of false
so inside the loop if i find what i'm
looking for i'm going to set b found to
be equal to true
and i don't need an else clause
because if we don't find what we're
looking for b found will never get set
to true and when we exit the loop b
found will still be false
all that remains to be done now is to
test be found once we get out of the
loop to see if it's equal to true
let's see what happens
we'll start by looking for something
that we know is in the list
found it just one message
let's try again we'll search for
something else that we know is in the
list
yes there's a fig
what about something that isn't in the
list
not found
now just a couple of words of warning
when you're comparing strings in vb.net
string comparisons are case sensitive so
for example if i search for banana with
a small b
not found however banana with a large b
is found
you've seen something similar to this in
an earlier video i can remove the case
sensitivity of a string comparison like
this
so i'm comparing the uppercase version
of the target with the uppercase version
of the array item
i can achieve exactly the same effect
like this
l case means lowercase so i'm comparing
the lowercase version of the target with
the lowercase version of the item in the
array
and it's probably worth mentioning this
as well
i can use dot 2 upper instead of u case
now there's one more improvement i can
make to the efficiency of my program if
i find what i'm looking for there's no
point in examining all of the other
items in the array
if b found gets set to true then we can
force an exit from the for loop
for example if we're searching for apple
and we set b found to true there's no
point in looking at all of the other
items in the array we already know it's
there
so there you have it
a standard linear search
if you're going to write code to create
and manipulate a two-dimensional array
variable
it's essential that you can visualize
the data you're working with
very often a two-dimensional array
variable is used to store groups of
related data items like the data you can
see here
a two-dimensional array can therefore be
thought of as a table
these are the data we're going to use in
this video
each row of the table contains the
details of a different famous person
the first column contains their first
names the second contains their last
names
the third column is gender
then we have nationalities and finally
their occupations what it is each person
is famous for
notice that each column has an index
number
counting starts from zero so the fifth
column is column number four
each row also has an index number and
these are also numbered from zero
it's useful to think of this table as
having a horizontal dimension which
we'll refer to as the x dimension
and the vertical dimension which we'll
refer to as y
just like the x and y axes of a line
chart
when you're coding up a two-dimensional
array for a different set of data i
strongly recommend that you keep a
sketch of it handy like i'm going to do
now
i can declare my two-dimensional array
variable like this
i'm using a naming convention here
a because it's an array variable st
because it's an array of strings and
people because that's what the data is
in brackets i've specified the x
dimension first followed by a comma and
then the y dimension
and i've used the as clause to specify
that this is an array of strings
now i'm keeping my sketch of the data
handy while i populate this array
it's important to get this right
otherwise you might get some very
peculiar behavior when you run your
program
i want to put barrack in the first
column and the first row
i want obama in the second column and
the first row
the third column first row contains mail
and column number three row number zero
contains american
it takes a little bit of getting used to
counting from zero
and the final piece of data for this
person is president
now it's tempting to start copying and
pasting but i want to make sure i get
this absolutely right so i'm going to
continue entering the values
individually just for now working from
my sketch
let's get the new zealand prime minister
in next
as with the previous famous person i've
specified the column number first
followed by the row number i've
specified x followed by y
notice that the value of x is different
for each data item but the value of y is
always the same because y is the row
number
let's do one more very carefully and
then i'll speed things up with a bit of
copying and pasting
and i've just realized that i've made a
mistake it's very easy to do
that's more like it now you could
initialize each individual element of
this array in any order you like the
important thing being that it's fully
initialized but taking a systematic
approach like this will help to ensure
if not guarantee you won't make any
silly mistakes a systematic approach
will also help to ensure that all of the
data gets in there
but i can see a pattern emerging now so
i'm going to start copying and pasting
to speed things up a little bit
now one last look at my sketch just to
make sure i've got everything there that
should be there
and straight away i can see i need to
change these twos to fives
and there it is the code i need to
declare and populate my two-dimensional
array
so that's how we get data in how do we
get data out
it's actually very simple if you've ever
played a game like battleships
with this message box statement i'm
going to output whatever is in column 4
row three in this case the word
scientist
what if i want to output let's say new
zealand
that's in column three row one
or perhaps the word swiss that's row
three column three
it's just a matter of supplying the
appropriate coordinates
i can also supply these coordinates
using
variables now i could call these
variables anything i like but it makes
perfect sense to call them x and y
can you see which data item will be
output by this message box
let's see
now just like a one-dimensional array
the real power of a two-dimensional
array is realized when you combine it
with looping constructs
let's suppose i want to output all of
the information about barack obama
notice that with barack obama it's the x
dimension which is changing from zero to
four but the y dimension remains at zero
i can do this
in fact i don't even need the variable y
suppose instead i want to output the
details of mahatma gandhi again it's the
x value which varies but the y value
stays the same in this case y remains at
four
you should make sure that you're
comfortable with this idea before you
continue
let's try ada lovelace ada lovelace is
in row number two so the value of y has
to remain the same inside this loop it
has to be two
alternatively i might decide that i want
to display all of the values in a
particular column for example i might
want to display all of the last names
if we examine the data we can see that
every last name has the same value of x
obama is one zero ardern is one one
lovelace one two einstein won three
gandhi is one four and van gogh is one
five
it's the value of y which is changing
this time
so i could write my loop like this
but notice that y varies from zero to
five
so this time it's the value of x which
is remaining the same inside the loop
but y is the value that changes
perhaps i want to display all of the
nationalities
looking at the code i can see that all
of the nationalities have an x value of
3.
again you should make sure that you're
comfortable with doing this before you
proceed
in the next video i'll show you how we
can get all of the data out using nested
loops
in this video i'm going to show you how
you can systematically visit each and
every item in a two-dimensional array
as in the previous video i recommend
that you keep a sketch of your data
handy to help you visualize what's going
on
here's a sketch of the data i'm working
with
you may for example want to display all
of the data items one at a time row by
row like this
the data are being visited one whole row
at a time but as each row is visited
every column in the row is visited
we say that the data in the array are
being visited row wise
here's what the output of a program that
does this looks like
alternatively you might want to visit
the data column wise like this
a program that does this deals with one
complete column at a time
but as each column is visited all of the
rows in that column are visited
and here's what the output would look
like
if you can systematically visit all of
the data items in an array one way or
another then you can collect the data
into a single output string then output
everything at once like this
visiting the data also allows you to
search for something in particular
for example you can ask the user for a
surname and then find all the details of
that person like this
so let's take a look at some code and
see how this can be done
i'll begin by writing some code to
display the data row wise
i've already declared the array and i've
already initialized all of the elements
of the array just to speed things up
this is the same data which you saw in
the previous video
i need two loop counters because i'm
going to use
nested for loops
if i want to visit one row at a time i
need a for loop like this
because each row is numbered from zero
to five
but while i'm visiting a particular row
i want to visit each column and i can do
it with a for loop like this
the columns are numbered from 0 to 4.
think of it this way for each pass of
the outer loop there will be several
passes of the inner loop
and now i'm going to output a data item
for each pass of the inner loop
let's see what happens when we run the
program
now let's display the data column wise
i'm using a different button to run this
program but i'm going to copy and paste
some code
it's the same code i used to declare and
initialize the array
in a later video i'll show you how two
different procedures can share the same
data
for now we'll proceed like this
to visit the data column wise i'm going
to use nested loops again
but this time i'm going to scan the
columns primarily so i'm going to scan
across the x dimension using my outer
loop
and as i visit each column i'm going to
visit each row within that column
and i need another message box as before
let's see how it looks this time
to display all of the data in a single
message box i need to decide whether i'm
going to build the output string in a
row-wise fashion or a column-wise
fashion
i'm going to do it row-wise so again i'm
going to borrow some code
this is the code that displays the data
items individually but column wise
i need a string variable to collect the
data into
and then rather than displaying a
message box for each pass of the inner
loop i'm going to concatenate some new
data to the output string
and between each data item i'd like a
space
because i want each row of data to
appear on a separate line within the
message box i'm going to concatenate a
vb new line character onto the output
string but only with each pass of the
outer loop
and once the nested loops have both
finished i can do one output with a
single message box
let's see if it works
the final thing i want to show you is
how we can search for the details of a
particular person based on their surname
for example
i don't actually need nested loops to do
this i'm going to use the same technique
which i showed you in the previous video
let's start by declaring and
initializing the array
and i need some loop counters
and i'm going to use a boolean variable
to record whether or not i found what
i'm looking for
i'm going to initialize it as false
although to be honest i don't need to do
that because immediately after it's been
declared it will have a value of false i
just want my code to be explicit
i'll prompt the user for the target
surname using an input box just to keep
things simple
so i'm going to need a variable to hold
the target value
i know that the surnames are in column
number one so i'm going to write a loop
to scan down the rows of column number
one only testing each value as i go
notice how i've hard coded the value of
the x dimension here i'm always looking
at column number one
as i scan down the column if the data
item which i'm looking at matches the
target then i'll set my boolean variable
to be equal to true and i can force an
exit from this for loop
by the time i've dropped out of the loop
i know whether or not i've found what
i'm looking for
if i have then i can retrieve the rest
of the data for that particular person
notice this time i'm scanning across the
row
the value of y will be whatever it was
when the first for loop came to an end
so i know this loop is looking at the
correct row
if b found was equal to false
then we simply display a message saying
that we can't find what the user was
looking for
there's one final thing we need to add
to this code
let's see it in action
that seems to be working fine
and just to be sure let's look for
somebody who isn't in the array
that looks okay as well
having said that we have an additional
message box here which is rather untidy
let's put this right
that's better
you should try writing some of these
programs yourself
perhaps you could display the data
column wise but within the same message
box or maybe build a search facility
where you enter the person's occupation
to retrieve all of their details